من هجمات ايران في العراق الى قصف تركيا
على مناطق سيطره قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في ارياف محافظه حلب والرقه وايضا الحسكه
قصف ادى الى سقوط قتلى وجرحى مدنيين
وعسكريين على حدن سواء وبينما قال المرصد
السوري ان عدد قتل الضربات التركيه على
شمال سوريا ارتفع الى 35 ذكرت وكاله هاوار
الكرديه ذكرت ان القذف التركيه تجدد على
الريف الغربي لمدينه عين العرب طبعا هي
تابعه لمحافظه حلب السوريه مصادر كرديه
افادت ايضا بان قصفا بالمدفعيه الثقيله
وقذائف الهاون استهدف بلده شيوخ فوقاني
وقران محيطه طبعا الناطق الرسمي قصد اعتبر
ان لدى تركيا رغبه في التوسع وفي ضم
المزيد من الجغرافيا السوريه كما اضاف ان
قصد لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي ستدافع عن
مناطقها حياه اي تواقل